angelina jolie says she's ready to make
her return to the big screen i'm a
little nervous but very excited
[Music]
angelina has kept a low profile over the
last year following her split from brad
pitt she didn't take on any new film
projects and actually hasn't acted on
screen since 2015's by the sea you know
my reason but now the 42 year old mom of
six is back to work promoting her new
netflix project first they killed my
father at the telly ride film festival
the director got a standing ovation
after the premiere of the movie and told
the hollywood reporter this in a post
screening interview
quote right now i don't have anything to
direct that i feel passionate about so
i'll do some acting i've taken over a
year off now because of my family
situation to take care of my kids while
she hasn't committed to anything yet
it's likely the long-planned sequel to
2014's maleficent will be her next
on-screen role
i still have my horns at home still
angelina told the crowd at telly ride
that one day she will likely give up
acting completely to focus on directing
how are you a mother to six and the
director and the writer of a movie how
do you balance home
you have to be a little crazy
[Music]
you